Speaker 1: There's some interesting news,
which is it's good news, but it's also not
nearly enough.
New York is going to be raising the age to
buy an assault rifle from 18 to 21.
And New York is going to be banning body armor.
Widely reported, including by Bloomberg.
Governor Kathy Hochul and legislative leaders
pledged to raise the legal age to purchase
an Air 15 assault rifle in New York to 21
from 18 and pass a package of measures to
tighten gun laws before the end of the state's
legislative session this week, citing the
mass shootings in Buffalo, New York and Nevada.
Texas local officials say they want to close
loopholes and address the gaps in laws exposed
by the back to back massacres.
The bills would prohibit the purchase of body
armor for civilians, require a license to
purchase a semiautomatic rifle, make threatening
mass harm a crime, and strengthen the state's
red flag laws.
The measures would also require new pistols
to have micro stamping technology, which uses
lasers to implant marked imprint markings
to make it easier to trace guns to registered
owners.
Illinois, Washington, Hawaii and Florida have
already raised the age from 18 to 21 for assault
rifles.
So this is great, right?
But neighboring Pennsylvania, you still only
have to be 18.
To buy an assault rifle in neighboring New
Jersey.
You still have to be only 18 to buy an assault
rifle.
And in New Jersey, adults can buy and use
bulletproof vests and body armor unless you
have a felony conviction.
And in Pennsylvania, there are no extra body
armor regulations besides federal laws.
So in Pennsylvania, adults can still buy and
use bulletproof vests.
And you could say, well.
But David, it would be against the law to
cross state lines.
Right.
Yeah, but it's still extraordinarily easy
to do.
And so you get the idea we need some kind
of broader probably federal legislation on
a lot of this stuff.
Now, one of the things we have to remember
is if the crime is going to be where there's
more population and we've got a piece planned
on this issue of the gun violence is in so-called
Democrat cities.
You all know, as I've explained before, cities
in general lean, Democratic and high crime
cities and low crime cities are basically
run by Democrats.
Democrats just live in cities and crime is
more prevalent where there is more population
density.
So we might understand, well, the population
centers are where you're going to see more
crime.
But if it's that easy for people to go to
Jersey and Pennsylvania for the weapons or
to go from Chicago into Indiana, this type
of thing might actually backfire statistically
in what shows up good for New York City, good
for the state of New York.
But we really need a national effort here.
Now, in terms of 18 versus 21.
I would actually go to 25 on semiautomatic
assault weapons now, you might say.
But, David, why not ban them altogether?
Sure.
I'm trying to be realistic to some degree.
And when you look at the ages of many of these
mass shooters, you have a situation where
you've overwhelmingly got shooters under 25
using a semiautomatic assault rifles.
So you could deal with a ton of the mass shootings,
specifically by targeting those firearms and
those individuals.
Now, of course, we should be doing much more.
And as I've said before, what you do to deal
with gun suicides versus individual gun homicides
versus mass shootings, three different problems,
three different sets of solutions.
We talked about this Tuesday on the bonus
show with Pat.
But this is at least one thing that can be
done.
And, you know, unfortunately, in my interview
in the last segment, Congressman Jamie Raskin
was not super optimistic that this time it's
going to go differently in terms of getting
Republicans on board to actually do something.
But even though it's not enough, even though
it doesn't go far enough, even though it's
not happening in enough places to make a difference,
yet New York is at least doing something.
Listen, Canada is doing more as a result of
mass shootings in the United States than the
United States is doing.
And we'll talk about that on the bonus show.